are you ready to brid the gap between
data and business success welcome to
Simply learn and today we bring you the
perfect tutorial on how to become a
business analyst in 20124 in a rapidly
changing corporate landscape skilled
business analysts are The Navigators
guiding organizations towards informed
decisions and strategic Excellence our
tutorial video is your compass in this
time Dynamic World designed to empower
you with the knowledge tools and
strategies necessary to become a
proficient business analyst from
deciphering complex data sets to
translating insights into actionable
strategies this tutorial will unlock the
secrets of the trade whether you're a
budding analyst or a professional
looking to sharpen your skills our
engaging tutorial will illuminate the
path to becoming a valued asset in any
organization that said if these are the
type of videos you'd like to watch then
hit the like And subscribe button and
the bell icon to get notified also if
you're an aspiring business analyst
looking for online training and
certifications from the prestigious
universities in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply launch postgraduate program and
business analysis from FD University in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be your right choice
more details head straight to our
homepage and search for business
analytics postgraduate program from bird
University or or simply click on the
link in the description box below so now
let's get started with the how to become
a business analyst in 2024 tutorial we
will get started by discussing the
agenda for today's session first we will
get started by understanding who is a
business analyst followed by that we
will go through the roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
next ahead we have the list of skills
needed by you to become a successful
business analyst with that discussed we
will proceed with the top companies
hiring business analyst along with their
salary compensations being offered we
will be wrapping up the video by
discussing the most important part of
today's session which is about the
process of becoming a professional
business analyst in 2024 now let's get
started with the first one who is a
business analyst a business analyst is a
professional who assesses an
organization's processes systems and
data to identify business needs problems
and opportunities they analyze data and
create detailed requirements
specifications and recommendations
for solutions to improve business
process increase efficiency and Achieve
strategic objectives business analysts
facilitate communication between
stakeholders and project teams ensuring
that technology and processes aligned
with business goals their role involves
data analysis documentation and project
management making them essential in
decision making and project
implementation within an organization
now moving further into the roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
here are some of the top roles goals and
starting with understanding business
needs business analysts work closely
with stakeholders to understand the
organization's objectives challenges and
needs they identify opportunities for
improvement and Define project goals
next is requirements Gathering they
collect and document detailed
requirements for various stakeholders
including end users to ensure that
projects align with business objectives
third one is data analysis business
analysts analyze data to identify Trends
patterns and insights that can inform
decision making they may use statistical
tools and techniques to interpret data
moving ahead we have process mapping the
document to analyze existing business
process identifying bottlenecks and
areas for optimization they also design
and propose new process where needed
fifth one in the list is solution design
business Anders collaborate with
technical teams to design solutions that
meet business requirements they may
create functional specifications and
system design documentations next ahead
is communication effective communication
is the key business analyst facilitate
communication between business
stakeholders and Technical teams
ensuring that everyone is on the same
page next one on the list is testing and
quality assurance they often participate
in testing activities to verify that
Solutions meet requirements and are free
of defs moving ahead we have change
management business handers help manage
the change associated with implement ing
a new process or systems ensuring a
smoth transition and user adoption the
ninth one on the list is documentation
they maintain comprehensive
documentation including requirements
process flows and project plans to
provide a clear record of project
activities and lastly we have project
management some business analysts may
take on project management
responsibilities ensuring that projects
are delivered on time and within budget
these roles and responsibilities can
vary depending on the organization and
the specific project business analysts
play a crucial role in Bridging the Gap
between business needs and Technical
Solutions ultimately contributing to the
success and efficiency of the
organization moving ahead we shall get
into the skills required to become a
successful business analyst in 2024 so
business analysts require a combination
of Technical and non-technical skills to
excel in their roles here are some
important technical skills for a
business analyst starting with data
analytics business analyst should be a
profession ient in data analysis
techniques including data mining data
modeling and statistical analysis tools
like Excel SQL and data visualization
software like tab Loop powerbi or often
used next is requirements management
familiarity with requirements management
tools and methodologies is essential
tools like Microsoft Vis jira or
specialized requirements management
software help in documenting and
tracking requirements next is process
modeling knowledge of process modeling
techniques and tools such as bpmn which
is business process model and notation
helps in visualizing and documenting
business process next in the list is
database skills basic database skills
include the ability to write SQL queries
and understand database structures that
are valuable and are very helpful for
assessing and analyzing data next in the
list is programming languages while not
always require Proficiency in
programming languages like python or R
can be advantageous especially for
handling and analyzing large volumes of
data sets for automating tasks sixth one
is business intelligence tools
understanding how to use business
intelligence tools can Aid in data
visualization and Reporting tools like
TBL Loop Abbi and clip view are commonly
used next is project management tools
familiarity with project management
tools like Microsoft Project or agile
project management software can be
beneficial especially when managing
project timelines and tasks eighth one
on the list is data warehousing
knowledge of data warehousing Concepts
and tools can help business analyst work
with large data sets efficiently next on
the list is Erp systems so understanding
enterprise resource planning or Erp
systems like sap Oracle or Salesforce
can be valuable when analyzing data and
requirements in organizations that use
these systems next in the list is
Version Control Proficiency in Version
Control Systems like git can be
beneficial when collaborating with
documentation or working with
development teams 11th one on the list
business process automation familiarity
with automation tools and techniques can
be useful for identifying opportunities
to streamline processes and improve
efficiency lastly software development
life cycle or sdlc an understanding of
sdlc methodologies example agile
waterfall Etc is crucial for aligning
business requirements with development
process remember that the specific
technical skills required can vary
depending on the industry and
organization being adaptable and willing
to learn new tools and Technologies is
also an important skill for a business
analyst as the field continues to evolve
now let us discuss the company's hiring
business analysts so here are the names
of top 10 companies known for hiring
business analysts Deo Accenture IBM weny
and Company Amazon Microsoft Google JP
Morgan Chase andco Facebook and Oracle
now let's discuss the salary
compensation given to these business
analysts so if you are in India and a
beginner level business analyst or an
entry-level business analyst then you
can expect salaries ranging from 3 lakhs
to 6 lakhs per anom if you're an
intermediate candidate with 2 to three
years of experience then you can expect
salaries ranging from 6 to 12 lakhs per
Anum if you're an experienced candidate
with more than 5 years of experience in
business analysis then you can expect a
salary ranging from 12 lakhs to 20 lakhs
per anom and if you are in US USA and an
entry-level business analyst then you
can expect salaries ranging from $50,000
to $80,000 per anom if you're an
intermediate candidate with two to three
years of experience then you can expect
salaries ranging from $80,000 to
$120,000 per Anum and if you're a highly
experienced candidate that is more than
5 years of experience then you can
expect the salaries ranging from
$120,000 to $160,000 perom now let us
move ahead and understand how to become
a business analyst discovering the path
to becoming a proficient business
analyst involves a series of strategic
steps starting with defining your
objective start by gaining deep
understanding of the role and
responsibilities of a business analyst
explore blogs and online courses to
clarify your goals and interest in this
field next is Educational Foundation
typically a bachelor's degree is initial
requirement for an entry-level business
handers position pursuing Advanced
degrees such as Masters can also
significantly enhance your prospects in
this competitive field next is sharpen
your skills to thrive as a business
analyst it's vital to develop specific
skills the top five essential skills
include Proficiency in business
analytics problem solving capabilities
effective communication stakeholder
analysis and Technical expertise
communication skills in particular play
a pivotal role as a business analyst
bridge the gap between various teams and
stakeholders next is certification
earning online business analy
certification can validate your
competencies and help you update with
the latest tools and Technologies while
not always mandatory C ifications can
set you apart from the job market and
open doors for career growth next is
gain Real World Experience practical
experience is invaluable engage in real
world business analytics projects to
apply your knowledge and grasp the
Practical aspects of the profession this
hands-on experience will not only boost
your skill set but also deepen your
understanding of business operations
next is build your portfolio create a
comprehensive portfolio showcasing your
practical projects assignments
internships and certific ation this
portfolio serves as a testament to your
capabilities and can significantly
impact your job prospects moving ahead
we have job applications once you have
acquired the necessary training and
experience it's time to apply for
business analy positions tailor your
resume to highlight your achievements
and skills making a strong first
impression lastly research and
preparation prior to applying research
prospective employers and their specific
requirements daily your application and
interview preparation accordingly
demonstrating your commitment and
knowledge of the business and its needs
by following these steps you will be
well equipped to embark on a fulfilling
career as a business analyst whether
you're aiming to start as a junior
business analyst or aspired to higher
positions continuous learning and
practical experience are your keys to
success and with that we have reached to
the end of this session on how to become
a business analyst in 2024 do you need
any assistance or any of the resources
used in this course code like PP Etc
then please do let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts we'll be more than happy to help
you as soon as possible until next time
thank you and keep learning stay tuned
for more from Simply staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certific ation programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here